all of egyptian food is very fatty and
very delicious uh i think my favorite
meal is something called
okay uh so that's basically fried
eggplant with minced meat cool all right
and it's just layered and then it goes
into the oven so that's what you have
you have the fried eggplant that's
interesting
with minced meat uh
duck
we love hairy duck
uh pigeons we also eat pigeons here
wait you eat pigeons yeah i'm pleased
no no i'm not gonna make fun of it i
think that would be i wish we ate pigeon
here because it would solve the problem
you know what i mean we have way too
many of them and if if if pigeon became
popular we'd have clean statues you know
oh my god yeah so here so here stuffed
pigeons are like the the
one of the most famous dishes here in
egypt is it is it tastes good what does
a pigeon taste like it's kind of like
duck okay
but it's a bit sweeter
wow it's a bit sweeter i'm intrigued i
want to have i want to eat a pigeon now
well well when you come to cairo i would
like feed you
tons of pigeons
i'm glad that you're not listing just
fast foods you know american fast food
that you actually seem to love your
culture and and seem loyal to it is
there fast food there everything so we
have everything we all we have all of
the big franchises here
uh it's all open
like donuts fast food burgers everything
okay i always get bummed out when i go
to a foreign country yeah and
it's it's fine but when i see all the
restaurants that americans have here and
it's the first thing i see when i go to
this very exotic place like cairo
and there's an arby's there you know
what i mean do you have art do you like
arby's yeah i love arby's so basically
here i love eating arby's here in cairo
specifically i think in my opinion it's
the best
fast food chain here
because it's delicious
so you like arby's and do they have i do
sometimes if you go to say a mcdonald's
in france you can get uh you can get
some red wine with your meal because
they've made cultural adjustments okay
if i go to an arby's can i get a pigeon
with curly fries
i could suggest that they still haven't
reached that level yet well i think they
should if arby's wants to be culturally
sensitive
uh you know the fact that they're in
cairo they should order you should be
able to get a shredded
pigeon sandwich with curly fries
well that would be really nice
yeah it's easy you just run a lawn mower
over a bunch of pigeons oh no oh
what
what's the way to do it quickly
[Music]
no there are other ways well pigeons are
small i think that they're easy to
handle you don't need a lawnmower i love
that
i love that we've got nerums
[Laughter]
you're going into the like no no there's
actually a better way to do it uh for
arby's you're actually going to be the
arby's consultant for having a pigeon
yeah in the pigeon sector but the other
but other like chains here they do some
cultural adjustments
like for example mcdonald's they do some
cultural adjustments here especially for
example in ramadan
they they they like add a couple of
ramadan drinks to their menu oh good
yeah yeah but rv still hasn't reached
that level yet yeah no well let's let's
get on the let's get on the ball arby's
that's just a message to arby's yeah
because those people i know those people
very well i actually don't um
they pay me not to mention them